Earlier this month I made a trip from Ireland
to Dubai and as the plane climbed to cruising
altitude we were treated to the most amazing
sunset, from 12 kilometres in the sky.
I had this moment of awe and gratitude that
we live in a time where experiences like this
are possible and the feeling just got stronger
when I arrived in Dubai and saw the Burj Khalifa.
The building defies belief, I lived in Malaysia
for 3 years and used to love watching the
Petronas twin-towers glimmering in the distance
as I drove through the hills of Bangsar.
Those towers held the title of the tallest
building until 2004, but the Burj Khalifa
is almost twice the height.
I found myself looking up the tower and where
I expected it to stop it just kept going,
soaring further than I thought possible.
It really got me thinking about how it’s
engineers managed to overcome the challenges
that faced them.
The battle to build higher captured the world’s
attention in the 1929 as the Chylser building
raised it’s secret spire like a proverbial
middle finger to the Bank of Manhattan Trust
building, after months of intense competition
to become the world’s tallest building.
It cemented Chrysler as a powerhouse in the
American automotive industry, becoming a symbol
of the company's power and technological prowess.
The soaring skyscrapers of Manhattan were
not only a symbol of the power of the companies
that built them, but were seen as an expression
of America’s optimism and wealth.
The explosion in growth in America was largely
fueled by the invention of the elevator and
the availability of cheap structural steel.
Frank Lylod Wright even proposed a The Illinois
a 1.7 kilometre tall building in 1956 and
while the building was theoretically possible,
it was completely unpractical.
Elevator technology had not advanced far enough
and building sway would have been a huge issue
for comfort.
Tall slender structures like this are susceptible
to wind induced vibrations.
Anyone that has seen lamp posts shaking in
the wind will have seen this in action.
So what’s happening here?
Let’s place a cylinder in a wind tunnel
and examine what happens as we increase the
air velocity.
In a steady flow of air, you would assume
that the net force on the cylinder would be
in the same direction, like this.
And you would be right, at lower speeds this
is the case.
Here the light pole would just bend in that
direction and while the wind speed and direction
may fluctuate, you wouldn’t see the consistent
back and forth vibrations.
As we increase the speed, the air begins to
separate from the surface of the cylinder
creating two symmetrical eddies behind the
cylinder.
Eddies are regions of slow moving swirling
fluid.
You will see these a lot in rivers where branches
or bridge pillars block the flow.
Here is one in my hometown of Galway, Kayakers
use these eddies when they need to rest from
the fast moving mainstream.
If we keep increasing the fluid velocity these
eddies will grow and the force on the cylinder
will also grow, but as long as these eddies
are symmetrical the force will remain in the
direction of fluid flow, but there is a critical
moment where the system loses it’s stability.
The energy gradient from the main stream and
the slow moving eddies becomes too high and
the eddies begin to oscillate, at this point
a phenomenon called vortex shedding occurs
and the resultant force is no longer directly
downstream.
It teeters between the alternating low pressure
zones as the vortices are shed on either side
of the cylinder.
This can become a massive issue if the frequency
of the shedding matches the resonant frequency
of the structure.
That means that the direction of sway and
the direction of the force become synchronised
and the amplitude of the swaying is allowed
to grow as energy is being stored between
each cycle.
Every building dissipates some of that oscillation
energy through natural damping through it’s
materials and through friction at the joints,
but this is not always enough.
In these cases it is essential that the engineers
add mechanical dampers.
These are usually hidden away in the guts
of the building, but the world’s former
tallest building, The Taipei 101, decided
to open their 730 metric ton tuned mass dampener
to the public.
On August 8th 2015 a category 5 typhoon slammed
into Taiwan and set the Taipei 101s mass dampener
into motion and it was all recorded on a web
camera.
So what’s happening here, how does this
help stabilise the building.
When the tower is displaced the mass dampener
does not move with it immediately, it is left
behind and then begins to sway independently
of the building.
Now this is where the tuned part comes in.
The engineers will have tuned the damper to
the same frequency as the building, so when
the building sways to the right the damper
sways to the left and vica versa.
This creates an opposing force to the sway
which is transferred to the building through
these piston dampers and thus the kinetic
energy is dissipated and the magnitude of
the resonant motion is reduced.
Now what amazes me is that the Burj Khalifa
has no mass damper.
It simply relies on clever aerodynamics from
stopping those vortices from ever getting
organised enough to cause harmonic motion.
The reason light poles sway so easily is that
they have a consistent cross-section, allowing
those vortices to slough off uniformly along
the poles height.
So the same force is being applied at the
same time along the entire length.
One way engineers combat that is by placing
these helical spirals along the length of
cylindrical structures.
You occasionally see this with chimney stacks,
but also in offshore platforms as vortex shedding
can also happen in liquids.
The helical fins disrupts the fluid flow along
the length of the hull, preventing the vortices
from forming coherently.
The Burj Khalifa works in a similar manner
albeit in a much more elegant fashion.
The building’s footprint was inspired by
the desert hymenocallis flower and while this
is a beautiful design.
It provides an optimal amount of window space
while also allowing the steel reinforced concrete
frame to take this shape.
This central core provides excellent torsional
resistance while these y-shaped buttresses
provides fantastic lateral bending resistance,
similar to how an I-beam works.
(on screen)I’ll explain that in more detail
in a future video.
As the tower grows the building steps back
consecutively like this, This spiralling pattern
works exactly like the helical fin on the
platform earlier.
It prevents the vortices from sloughing off
the building coherently along it’s length
and so stop them from exciting the buildings
resonant frequency.
This is the genius of the building and why
is doesn’t need a mass damper.
The architects put meticulous care into the
buildings aerodynamic design using modern
computational analysis and wind tunnel tests
to ensure the structural integrity of the
building.
It is clear that with the continuous improvement
of technology, building these supertall buildings
is becoming less difficult and we are going
to continue seeing the title of tallest building
in the world swap hands in the coming years,
especially as the pressure to build higher
grows.
In 2007, the total urban population of the
world surpassed the 50% mark, 20 years ago
that figure was just 33% and that statistic
is expected to approach 80% by 2050.
Creating a functional city with adequate water
and energy supply and everything else that
comes with a densely packed population will
become an enormous challenge in the coming
years.
It is likely that these supertall buildings
will become less of a decadent symbol of power
and wealth and become a necessary and fundamental
part of the modern city.
Thanks for watching.
I really enjoyed making this video and I hope
you enjoyed watching it.
I have heard back from loads of you on how
much you are learning from TheGreatCoursesPlus
and thanks to your continued support they
have decided to sponsor another video.
So thank you to all my subscribers, patreon
supports and TheGreatCoursesPlus for helping
Real Engineering exist.
If you enjoy my videos you will definitely
like TheGreatCoursePlus.
They have over 7000 different lectures from
world renowned educators.
They have a huge range of topics, if you would
like to learn more about structural engineering
they even have a course for that or you can
learn about photography, chess and cooking.
These courses give you indepth knowledge on
a variety of subjects, while allowing you
to learn at your own pace without tests or
exams.
You can get a free one month trial by going
to the TheGreatCoursesPlus.com/RealEngineering
If you would like to see more content or support
real engineering the links for my Patreon,
Instagram, Facebook and twitter accounts are
below.